my very first trip to Africa was in
college I was an undergraduate and I
studied at the University of Nairobi and
had a remarkable experience for me in
many ways life-changing what I saw in
Kenya and also in Uganda and Tanzania
was literally for me breathtaking a
poverty something that shook me to my
core I'll never forget my first time
walking through Mathare Valley in
Nairobi it's seemingly endless slum
fills low rising Hills massive
corrugated metal dirt roads animals and
people crowded in a constantly jumbling
mass it's difficult to imagine unless
you live there or have been there and
while there is poverty in every nation
on earth including our own the depth of
poverty in the slums of the developing
world is really unmatched both re today
is home to more than half a million
kenyans and they live without running
water without sewers without access to
basic health care or education adequate
food or any sort of public safety
services homes are constructed really
from garbage from corrugated tin from
cast-off components of others lives and
the stench of that slum is unbearable
and unforgettable to all but those
forced to live there day in and day out
you cannot in my view really know abject
poverty until you've seen it with your
own eyes and been confronted by its
depth and by its painful persistence
that particular day I saw and in the
months that unfolded after that my own
faith was deeply challenged and shaped
by the experiences that I had in Kenny
had changed the way I looked at my own
country and at the economic disparities
here and between here and the rest of
the world I saw something else though
all across Kenya in places where I
worked urban and rural as a volunteer
both on that trip and when I returned
subsequently which was in striking
contrast to the material poverty of the
folks with whom I visited and that was
just an astonishing openness kindness
gentleness willingness to welcome and
embrace strangers and visitors that was
utterly unexpected and in some ways
humbling I remember my first church
service in the in gong hills at
presbyterian church I grew up in a
wonderfully suburban somewhat frozen
Chosin sort of church in New Castle
County Delaware and the service that I
joined their went on not for an hour not
for two hours not for three hours but
went nearly four hours and was
punctuated repeatedly with spontaneous
demonstrations of joy that weren't just
a few moments long but turned into
entire parades of the congregation
through the whole village dancing and
singing and shouting hallelujah and
praise to God and at one point a woman
sitting next to me turned and said are
you a missionary and I said no but if
you've got any spare moments I'd love it
if you'd come in witness to the church
where i grew up we in our incredible
material wealth desperately needed the
intensity the passion of their
acceptance of and joy for God something
I had not ever seen in that same depth
in my own community where I've been
raised and that challenged my faith that
folks so poor a material wealth were so
in abundant in their love for God and in
their willingness to welcome others it
was heartbreaking to me just how
incredibly gracious and generous these
people could be visiting once a family
in a rural area when I was working with
wanna walk away mondeo they I learned
had slaughtered their very last goat in
order to provide an adequate meal
welcoming strangers from another country
and we were as three strangers arriving
in Abraham's tent something that for me
had resonance with the greatest
traditions of hospitality to strangers
to angels among us from the very most
ancient of times and it was just five
years after these original experiences
in Africa that I spent my time at the
Yale Divinity School and it helped me
explore the questions that had been
raised for me in the context of my faith
and I am thrilled tonight to be able to
join with scholars and friends with
fellow alumni for this important
dialogue concerning many of these same
issues at the intersection of faith and
poverty I want to thank Dean Attridge
and the other organizers for inviting me
to participate and the press club for
hosting us this evening today is of
course Ash Wednesday and we stand
tonight on the threshold of Lent a
season hopefully for all of us in
different ways of reflection of
repentance end of sharper focus
lent should be a time when we consider
the number and significance of our good
works of our open-hearted responses to
God's calling in God's grace and when we
measure the seriousness of our sacrifice
which in many ways are the truest
measures of ourselves as I prepared for
this visit with you tonight I thought a
great deal about that time now more than
25 years ago when I first spent months
in Africa but as much about what
happened to me after I returned to the
US as when I was actually there in the
two or three years following my initial
return from Kenya I was shall we say a
constant reminder to everyone around me
of the troubles facing that continent
whether they really wanted to hear it or
not seeing the poverty of Mathare II and
other places in East Africa lit the fire
of activism within me and drove me to
become ceaselessly involved as only the
young really can as an activist for
human rights and for poverty relief and
I spent the last year of college and
then two years afterwards dedicated to
the fight against apartheid first in
Washington and then with the South
African council of churches and I then
returned after that to Kenyan to Uganda
to do some relief work with the
presbyterian church before ultimately
deciding after a lengthy late night
conversation with a priest friend who is
today the Bishop of Johannesburg to
return to the country from which I came
and try and work individually to
confront poverty at its most abject here
I went to working with the homeless in
New York City and found in the homeless
shelters of Fort Washington and over the
five states where I went in the year
that followed with the National
Coalition for the homeless a similarly
deeply challenging exposure to what
abject poverty means in this richest of
countries but also incredibly
challenging moments of grace of profound
witness of closeness to what I believe
to be the Living God the neighbor that
we are called to but so often failed to
really see in those who are all around
us it was my time at Yale but help me
understand the connection between my
faith and God and the effect my
experiences in Africa and with the
homeless had in motivating me to work
not just for charity or for relief but
for justice and reconciliation
while at Yale I was a student intern a
pastor with the downtown cooperative
ministry in New Haven one of America's
poorest and most challenged cities and
it was an opportunity there for me to
see a multi-faith congregation coalition
working to try and address issues of
housing of homelessness in the context
of a city that is also home to one of
the nation's best endowed universities
it was after that time that I returned
home to Wilmington Delaware into the
state where I grew up and I chose as the
place to worship an inner-city church
that was not just actively welcoming to
the homeless but actually is today a
full-time homeless shelter a church West
Presbyterian so dedicated to mission
that it literally succeeded in spending
itself out of existence I served on the
session and will not soon forget the day
when our accountant and chief finance
officer said to us if we continue on the
path we're on of relentless dedication
to mission we will close our doors in
less than five years and the session
voted unanimously to continue and today
the church is closed and it's been
repurposed as a homeless shelter which
was in many ways what is initially
intended to be a place of grace and
respite for those most trouble among us
we really can't predict the journey of
our lives we really can't imagine how
things shown to us early on might
someday come back to us as a challenge
or an opportunity the years I spent in
Africa and working with the homeless in
New York and elsewhere were things that
I largely put aside for the decade that
I was raising three young children
working as in-house counsel the gore-tex
company and then beginning to get
involved in improving my local community
but ultimately in my first elected role
as County Executive responsible for
housing programs for half a million
people I returned to active and engaged
work with Habitat for Humanity with the
faith community in Delaware with the
local government that had turned away
from being engaged in providing safe
sanitary and decent housing and I found
those early formative experiences came
back powerfully and was a tremendous
opportunity for me to work with the
faith community in Delaware and with
government and to find effective relief
for the poor through housing I believe
life for us isn't
acta process of hearing and at times
ignoring what God is calling us to do
and of discerning how best to act upon
that call whether as an individual or as
a nation and with the help of the
guidance I received at the Divinity
School I think I've learned to recognize
that that strong and unique sense of
fulfillment that comes by witnessing
with and working with in partnership not
in charity those who suffer whether
individually the homeless in this
country or an entire continent and
finding ways to forge a closeness with
God through that I hope many of you here
know that same sense that same unusual
and profound feeling of getting out of
the boundaries of our professional lives
of our roles and instead seeing others
as they truly are as equal in creation
so in thinking about tonight and in
thinking about the onset of Lent I
realized that more than 25 years had
passed since my first visits to Africa
and frankly decades have passed since
active personal engagement with the
struggles with the poverty of many of
the developing nations of Africa had
been an important part of my life I
spent as I've mentioned the last 10
years of my life raising three young
children and helping build a business
and helping grow a career so it is
wholly appropriate that's a night's
event like the title of the journal
connected to it is reflections and if
you'll forgive me I've been reflecting
on the very circumstances that in a
roundabout way seem system at least
unexpectedly to have led me from being
the county executive of a small County
in Delaware to being not just a freshman
senator but the newly selected chair of
the Senate Subcommittee on African
affairs after 25 years of focusing on so
many other avenues for service I find
myself unexpectedly drawn back to a
place where work in partnership of the
faith community on Africa not in charity
but in partnership is going to be in
many ways the central call of my work in
the next few years as a person of faith
I find this striking perhaps even
providential interestingly i began my
day this morning at the Senate's weekly
prayer breakfast where joe lieberman
gave moving reflection about the nature
of sabbath he had an interesting comment
he quoted the hebrew
HUD ha Mon excuse me common who said
more than the Jewish people has kept the
Sabbath the Sabbath has kept the Jewish
people just as the Sabbath provides
observant Jews with a time for
reflection and much as Ramadan calls on
Muslims to focus on fasting prayer and
the pursuit of good works Lent provides
those of us in the Christian community
with a chance to repent and reflect on
the direction of our lives on my way
into the Senate buildings this morning
from Union Station I walked past a woman
it's just over 20 or so years ago I
worked with Mitch Schneider on the issue
of homelessness here in Washington some
of you may remember Mitch now long gone
there is still a shelter here which
bears Mitch's name I last saw him
literally the day before he became a
victim of suicide when he was testifying
in front of the DC City Council in his
usual passionate and endless way about
the importance of dealing with the
homeless there is a woman who sits at
the foot of the fountain in front of
union station who has been there every
day that I've come to Washington for 20
years and I realized as a senator I have
walked briskly past her virtually every
day of my last three months some of you
know her she has a face painted wildly
and tiger stripes she sits in rags and
often actually smiles and greets folks
who walked by her today I stopped and
said hello and simply tried to give her
that moment of equality of recognition
of someone who deserves my attention as
I've taken from hers it was a simple and
small act of kindness but lent I think
begins with such steps as these a
challenge towards basic human decency to
stop on the pathway that seems so set
for us so paved so predictable and to
reflect on where we've gone perhaps a
little astray I've always been awed by
Americans by our stunning generosity by
our capacity to be lifted up out of our
chairs by what we see on our televisions
of the suffering of the farthest corners
of the world whether it's the disasters
of the tsunami or the challenges of
those in Sudan Americans in response to
great natural disasters are
astonishingly generous hundreds of
millions of dollars poured to Haiti and
really
within hours of the worst earthquake in
modern times yet i'm also overcome by
our capacity for casual almost brutal
indifference to the suffering of those
in the grips of abject poverty that we
know exists in our world each and every
day most Americans know that roughly
20,000 children die every single day
worldwide from completely preventable
diseases that just literally for pennies
each could be cured and we spend more as
a people every day on soft drinks and
video games than any of us individually
do or than we collectively as a nation
do on tending to the poor and on feeding
the hungry and the homeless around the
world so I think my challenge as a
freshman senator is to not ever forget
as I have at times forgotten over the
last 25 years the challenge of the
poverty I saw before me in matheran the
pathway that I saw through it and the
challenges that I see for us today in
the United States the power of Lent I
think is that it is a moment for us to
change direction we as a country we as a
global community of those dedicated to
seeing others as neighbor and caring for
them have made real progress the
Millennium Development Goals give us a
measurable way to say that we have made
progress but we also at this moment have
to stop and reflect and say it is not
yet enough we are called we are
challenged as an exercise of our faith
to do more to be more engaged to be more
persistent to not forget and to not turn
back every major faith tradition teaches
that it is our calling our challenge not
just to see those who are poor among us
but to prefer them to act for them from
Isaiah to Luke from the Quran to the
Torah there are passages that challenge
each and every one of us regardless of
your tradition or background to put not
just some time aside for the poor to act
not just in charity but in a way that
focuses on justice on reconciliation and
on development I'm conscious of the
passage of time and want to get to the
panel I have many more reflection
in front of me but I think it might be
best for me to move for the reflections
of the panel I'm conscious that in North
Africa today and in places around the
world there's a dramatic movement
towards liberty towards democracy
towards change in countries that have
long sweltered under dictatorship and
I'm conscious that we can't really make
sustainable progress in tackling poverty
until we tackle development and
development is something that can only
be tackled in partnership with people
whose capacity to be free is supported
by those of us who believe that as a
free nation we have a remarkable model
to provide them I do think that in the
Senate at this moment we have an
enormous challenge just today on the
floor we voted down HR 1 which was the
House Republicans proposed budget it
makes dramatic and broad cuts in
spending of all types spending that
would improve the security and the
quality of life for our communities in
the United States and it would
significantly cut our investment in aid
and relief overseas at a time when
frankly far less than 1% of our total
federal budget less than thirty nine
billion dollars is dedicated to foreign
assistance development and relief I
think it's incumbent on all of us in the
faith community and around the country
to take a step back and to focus on the
long-term on the consequences for our
relationships with countries around the
world and our relationship with
ourselves and our faith if we were to
turn aside from the path that most of
the industrialized world has long been
on with us of seeking collaboratively to
lift up those who we are called to
consider as neighbor not just here but
around the world as i said we as a
nation have a amazing capacity to be
selfless and to be engaged in meeting
the real needs of others and we
similarly have a capacity to turn aside
and to focus narrowly on ourselves as we
come out of the worst recession in
modern memory it is completely
understandable that people all across
this country have pressed back hard
against commitments to foreign
assistance have questioned and
challenged whether the United States
government should be engaged in this at
all and some can say as some will that
perhaps giving by the faith community is
inevitably more effective more sustained
and more positive than the sometimes
of motivated investments and
contributions of the American government
the American people in my view that's a
dialogue in which we must together be
vigorously engaged it is only by hearing
broadly from the people of faith all
across this country that the people of
Congress your representatives and the
folks in our administration can know the
value that we place as a country in
investing in hearing the call that comes
from all of our religious traditions to
view others as neighbors and to care for
those neighbors as we would ourselves
and to lift them bless you out of the
abject poverty that so dominates the
lives of literally billions of our
fellow people as this day for me draws
to a close I can't help but conclude by
thinking about what the spirit of Lent
has been teaching to me today my day
began with Senator Lieberman's comments
about the Sabbath and the need for a
moment of reflection and the real
physical challenge of nearly walking
past a homeless woman who's been in my
path in different ways for much of the
last 20 years I move tomorrow to my
service as a senator and the challenge
of representing you in the fight to
sustained engagement with the whole
continent of Africa I ask for your help
as you go home tonight after this great
panel reflects digests discusses what
small concrete step will you take on
what path will you head what very real
investment or sacrifice are you willing
to make to see those who suffer and
struggle around the world not just as
objects of charity but as are very real
partners in transformation in
development in growth in faith and in
peace I hope we can begin that journey
together god bless